dis moi tout on veut faire une interview
première fois justement sans rapport
avec les marouani et tout ça une vraie
interview première phase on sait tous
que souza gauvreau travers du tout un
art
dis moi ton premier souvenir cinq ans
qu'un anniversaire et un anniversaire
dans une dans mon petit village à
juillac avec des éléphants des signaux
sur le mur tout ce que je me souviens
premiers souvenirs je crois que c'est ça
c'est assez nette d'ailleurs cinq ans ma
grand mère on habitait dans un petit
truc avec la radio sur la table tiens tu
avais pas ton père tu m'as tu es né de
père inconnu
tu peux l'écrire comme tu veux mais je
suis venu perrin que des études tu dis
finalement c'est très bien comme ça
ouais ouais ouais c'est très bien comme
ça on va dire que c'est très bien que
ouais ouais ça parce que ça m'a motivé
sam à tarbes auch
enfin connue non je le connais tu
connais maintenant je le connais je
fréquente et enfin j'ai croisé pendant
des années il ya quelques temps je vais
parler et puis il reste un peu table
pour lui ouais t'as première balle
tandis que les copains mais parce que
justement c'est pas ta mère non sur
bompas surmonta mère elle s'appelait
d'aidé s'appelle toujours des vrais et
elle a un côté un peu non comme la merde
depardieu un peu parce que des partis d
une mère comme ça un peu l'avait
d'ailleurs ma mère ma mère c'est plus
que la moitié de moi c est le jouet 109
me ramasse la petite cuillère et puis
c'est un rocher c'est plus qu'un rocher
temps premiers flirts tu t'en souviens
way lorette s'appelait ouais c'est une
roue ce genre embrassé sur la joue je
suis parti en courant
c'est content j'avais 10 ans 10 11 ans
c'est bien la première 100 g j'ai une
mémoire fait j j'adore cette époque
première cuite
la première boîte je me rappelle bien
avec des potes avant deux à vendre la
veille de la rentrée des classes
on a fait quelque chose quand même ce
que c'est beau à laguiole à l'isara à
ses offres et sucre et non à boire c'est
dur à vomir
en fait c'est sucré
oh la la c'est une horreur et c'est ce
qu'on avait fait tellement on était
bourré on a voulu se faire du café gala
je ne conseille à personne il faut
vraiment être tordu pour le faire on a
pris la machine à laver en a mille café
moulu dans le truck coutumes et la
poudre à l'époque il y avait un tuyau
qui sortaient les saloperies on
attendait que avec ses mesures contre
1600 balle c'est sa honte et food avoir
30 francs ces 30 bal à l'époque l'abbé
au panier c'est 30 francs le pénitencier
7 et 30 francs pour du salut c'est 40
francs
c'était en 74kg vieux que ça c'est un
peu dur pour bouffer comme ton premier
vide trop plein à quelque 11 aces à
est-ce que j'ai pris on va voir pour
voir que maintenant j'ai appris ah ouais
j'ai appris mais non tu sais les nanas
moi j'ai pu citer réchauffement
complexes et un grand nez oreilles tout
est éprouvant
et comme les éléphants par lg2 chose de
l'éléphant j'ai la mémoire aussi et puis
en plus pendant des années je sais si je
me faisais des cauchemars et un jour
enfin parler joue autant je me faisais
des films et puis un jour je me suis dit
pourquoi tu es serré pas les mêmes mais
les très belles et celles qui sont sur
la couverture des magazines est tout
prêt aussi à chaque fois j'en croise il
non non c'est pas pour moi avez-vous est
en fait faut oser est-ce que c'est pas
plus dur mais pas bon
à bon entendeur salut est même des fois
tu te demandes si les belles sont pas
plus pratique
par exemple il habitait plus qu'elle
s'emballe ben ouais d'un premier mariage
ah c'est très bien c'est génial c'est
15h30 l'annoncé en nba 16 ans et demi
saisonniers qui dispense du président de
la république vous avez tiré ensemble en
crète il faut puis j'ai vendu mes tout
de suite ça j'assume et tout de suite
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu faire bouffer ma
femme bien c'est tout donc je me suis
mis à dos et j'ai même passé un concours
de flics que j'ai pas eu heureusement
s'imagine à julien informé en danger
lire dans le point
tu trouves un deuxième mariage on oublie
assez plus en parler de sa gauche
troisième mariage et truc ont besoin du
gâteau je connais ou c'est connu c'est
un copain qui m'a présenté sur un
plateau et puis après on s'est connu à
val d'isère dans un gala je fais partie
que les cocos coeur et je me disais dans
la catégorie coco girl lui manque qu'un
truc à ma collection
ouais chf le moment je suis heureux que
je reconnais que j'ai fait je me suis
fait un challenge à savoir je vais taper
je vais essayer coco girl
en fait c'est parti comme ça et je ne
suis pas du tout partie avec mais j'ai
vu que cette fille là si elle mettait la
main dessus
c'était cuit et on en fait on sait le
hasard si une chose bête on sait on
s'est vraiment connu le soir où connu
chez mort parce qu'elles habitaient chez
coluche c'est une amie devenue une amie
tout bien toute amitié
habiter chez coluche
et puis on s'est téléphoné soir la
gauche est mort le 19 juin 86 on s'est
revu ses mariés on a fait un petit lait
né le 19 juin
91 1 c'est bizarre fallait 20 et
entre-temps coluche c'est dur moto et
mon fils c'est dû aussi au hasard à
savoir c'est vrai que le petit benjamin
qu'elle agit là il ya six mois ouais
c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà coupé quatre
fois les cheveux et fait défiler comme
toi et bouge et c'est monstrueux guéri
mais moi je vais perdre mais c'est à lui
mais lui il a des cheveux ses
monstrueuses jamais vu ce dont on est
sûr qu'il a toi pas vraiment même si
l'été noir il sera bon ouais parce que
c'est des fois dans les maternités on
les mélange
ouais bah non je crois pour là ils se
croient pas qu'ils aient pu le mélange
et regarde